في ضفه الغربيه يترقب الفلسطينيون ان تفرج
اسرائيل اليوم الاثنين عن اكبر الاسرى
الفلسطيني عمرا وهو الاسير فؤاد الشوبكي
البالغ من العمر 83 عاما بعد ان امضى 17
عاما في السجون الاسرائيليه حيث سيتم
الافراج عنه من سجن عسقلان وسيكون هناك
استقبال احتفالي له في رام الله هذا يعد
الاسير الشوبكي سياسيا وعسكريا برتبه لواء
واحد اعضاء حركه فتح اختطفه الجيش
الاسرائيلي من سجن اريحا عام 2006 مع امين
عام الجبهه الشعبيه احمد سعد
من رام الله مشاهدينا ينضم الينا مراسله
عربيه خالد القاسم اهلا بك خالد وهل تاكد
موعد الافراج عن الاسير الشوبكي وكيف تبدو
الاستعدادات الاحتفاليه به في رام الله
لا تاكيدات حول الساعه قبل دقيقتين كنت
اتحدث مع نجله الاكبر الذي يتنقل ما بين
معبر الظاهريه ومعبر تركوميا لتضارب
الانباء الوارده من اداره مصلحه السجون
الاسرائيليه حول مكان اطلاق سراح فؤاد
الشوبكي او الساعه الدقيقه لاطلاق سراحه
وهذا ما اعتاد عليه الفلسطينيون
عند اطلاق سراح شخصيات سياسيه او اعتباريه
فلسطينيه يكون هناك تمويه في المكان
والموعد اما بالنسبه للاستعدادات فسيتم
استقبال الاسير او كما اصطلح على تسميته
شيخ الاسرى في هذا المركز الترويح التابع
لبلديه رام الله بعد ان يضع اقليلا من
الزهور على ضريح الرئيس الراحل ياسر عرفات
وهناك عده فعاليات احتفاليه تنتظره فور
وصوله الى مدينه رام الله طيب خالد ماذا
نعرف اذاعه شخصيه الشوبكي اسباب اعتقاله
في 2006
ومكانته ايضا او ما اذا كان يرمز او له
رمزيه بين جميع الاسرى الفلسطينيين في
السجون الاسرائيليه
يعني ما نعرفه عن فؤاد الشوبكي انه من
مواليد قطاع غزه عام 1940
انهى بكالوريوس المحاسبه من جامعه القاهره
وان التحق بصفوف الثوره الفلسطينيه منذ
بدايه انطلاقتها
وتنقل مع حركه فتح بين العواصم
بين دمشق والاردن وتونس وبيروت حتى عاد
ضمن اتفاق اوسلو عام
1995 ليسلمه الرئيس
الراحل ياسر عرفات المسؤوليه الماليه
للسلطه الفلسطينيه واسرائيل تتهمه بتمويل
كل الاعمال غير القانونيه للسلطه
الفلسطينيه اتهمته اسرائيل عام
2002 بتمويل
شحن سفينه اسلحه عرفت حينها بكرن ايه
اعترضتها البحريه الاسرائيليه الطيران
الحربي الاسرائيلي في البحر الاحمر
وصادرتها واعتقلت كل طاقمها تتهم اسرائيل
بتمويلها وارسال القوارب لنقل الشحنات الى
شواطئ قطاع غزه قالت اسرائيل بان الشحنه
شحنه الاسلحه قادمه من ايران حينها ضغط
على السلطه الفلسطينيه فتم اعتقال فؤاد
الشوبكي في السجن المركزي في اريحا لمده
اربعه اعوام عام 2006 حاصرت القوات
الاسرائيليه السجن الذي كان يخضع لحراسه
بريطانيه وامريكيه وفلسطينيه وقامت
باعتقال فؤاد الشوبكي ومجموعه اخرى منها
الامين العام للجبهه الشعبيه احمد سعادات
وعدد من اعضاء خليه اتهمت باغتيال الوزير
الاسرائيلي رحب عام ذئب